let's look at the moments that the death
of her majesty Queen Elizabeth II was
formally announced
this is the short statement
being brought to the gates of Buckingham
Palace
fixed to those Gates
and the statement is you can read for
yourself saying that uh
the queen
died peacefully at balmore this
afternoon the king and the queen consult
will remain at Balmoral and Will Travel
shortly
to London
that in actual fact as the Majesty has
passed
in Scotland Hollywood Palace
and these are the scenes at Buckingham
Palace
here in London the crowds Gathering
they've been Gathering all afternoon
since the initial statement from
Buckingham Palace concerning the Queen's
deteriorating Health was announced that
doctors were concerned for her
but she was comfortable during then the
course of the afternoon the senior
members of the Royal Family
gathered acts Balmoral the Queen's
summer residence she's been there she
has been every summer
for the entirety of that period where
she received two prime ministers in a
day just two days ago
here
the crowds gathered and the most
significant change of course
the flagpole above Buckingham Palace
where the Union flag has now been
lowered
to half-mast and we'll
remain at half-mast During the period of
mournering
as we remember the life the passing of
her majesty Queen Elizabeth II